when watching TV or the movies it's
something we take for granted smooth
steady shots that somehow move quickly
across the floor without any bumps or a
sense of vertigo you can thank Garrett
Brown his groundbreaking invention the
Steadicam gives camera operators a
steady hand when giving you shots like
these we met him about five years ago on
assignment for Sunday morning in the
throes of retirement but now he's back
with a new invention hoping to rock a
new wave of Mobility for those who don't
have it
does this ever get old no it's it's a
fantastic I love it up here when we
caught up with Garrett Brown five years
ago let's go are you doing it
we literally had to catch our breath
racing the same steps made famous in the
oscar-winning film Rocky
just added it up that was the fourth
time I've run up the stairs in in
Earnest to Rocky Rocky II Rocky five and
with you Michelle Miller
for CVS the contender what made Brown a
contender back in 1974 was what he gave
cinematographers a lightweight handheld
stabilizer that allowed them to move
with the action seamlessly
before cameras used dollies on Rails to
shoot movement after his creation
revolutionized Hollywood movie making
who could forget this scene from The
Shining
or this Chase in the Return of the Jedi
[Music]
now standard issue the Steadicam has
evolved Beyond film there's the sky Camp
the fly Camp the dive camp
it's a human machine interface which is
something that is enduringly interesting
to me and as a matter of fact this
present item is a human machine
interface and the Philadelphia native is
at it again
this time to help people with
disabilities move in real time mayor yes
this is
seated
and this
is standing and it made the move for me
you know he calls his latest invention
the zine what is it that we need we need
a comfortable chair we need to not have
to ditch that chair to get moving but
hey let's get to your feet without the
wine of motors and slow you know let's
get to your feet like a kid named after
the inventor of the pedalus bicycle
Baron vandres users maneuver it in much
the same way Riders did back then the 80
year old came up with the idea a decade
ago while visiting his then 97 year old
dad in care facilities I was watching
his Pals and something big seemed to me
missing between Walkers and wheelchairs
once you consign yourself to a
wheelchair your feet are not on the
ground particularly you're not upright
being upright is great for your cardiac
your bone density your your limbic
system your digestive system and its
particularly valuable for your
psychological well-being to be up among
your fellow humans is one of the things
we hear most often that they love about
this machine that's when the former folk
singer and voice-over actor got to work
these are your handlebars just push them
forward oh you just push it oh okay now
you've got seat belts on either side
squeeze these and drop all the way down
to a seated position okay let's go
it took about a decade of inventing and
tinkering make the rear spin around you
oh yeah there we go for brown and the
small team of Engineers to get the
machine just right come on I'm coming
come on
this is really agile it is it Maneuvers
well it is you can move you know in any
direction
as well yeah of course starting with
prototypes this is our history of oh
where this came from was this the first
one
took an old Walker and had this saddle
welded onto it just to see what's this
feel like you know wow some that look
rather ridiculous to him now you have to
be willing to look fairly Goofy and
silly when you're testing prototypes for
machines that work with humans
kidding them at Healthcare conventions
AARP conferences anywhere he could reach
people with limited Mobility
to date he's produced about a hundred
zines we'll head inside we'll get you
all set up with your new Zine awesome
good it's already attracting customers
like a Nami fatal who relied mostly on
our powered wheelchair and roll later
but the Rollator there's absolutely no
support all of my energy when I use that
requires me to focus on not falling
which is why I can't even use a Rollator
without assistance start bending your
knees send in your hips backwards just
sitting yourself down there you go all
the way down on the day of our visit she
tried out her new Zine not being able to
have said to stand yourself like that it
gives you back
something that you lost that you miss
every day yep so there you go it's
following you around the instant that we
give you this eight degree of freedom
and B
autonomy and that's an important word
with this when you're in it and you're
safe you're on your own it's become
almost a higher calling made even more
evident last fall when Brown traveled to
Rome to make a special delivery how did
that happen I was looking at a video
report of Pope Francis
struggling with Mobility I thought he
could use one of these things the letter
he wrote must have been convincing
because it went around the Vatican and
we were vetted and didn't we get back a
wonderful letter saying yes we accept
thank you very much and we heard later
it's in his apartment so
this story is unfolding no official
sighting no official sighting but you
know if if it's useful to Pope Francis
that would be really really satisfying
now drop yourself down okay any height
you care to Brown is hoping to get word
out to anyone who can benefit from the
zine that like his most famous invention
this new one
is here to help
inventing is what we do for a good life
I mean inventing a life is imagining
what you want
that is to say What's missing
and what do you have to do to get there
so just like the woman who was dancing
with her son at his wedding at their 29
million Americans who have mobility
issues and it is you know Garrett's hope
that he can help you know break into
that market to help as many people as he
can amazing freedom and autonomy yeah